The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Are you guys
excited about Battlecode?
I'm so excited to
see this many-- Yeah!
Yeah, let's hear a
hurray-- no, no a yeah.
Are you excited?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
PROFESSOR: All right,
that was a strong yeah.
I actually mean that.
I have a strange thing
where when I say something
it often comes out like I meant
the opposite of what I said,
like I didn't believe it.
Like that time that Drew
Houston-- from Dropbox,
he's the Dropbox CEO-- do
you guys remember this?
He was giving his sponsor talk
at the finals of Battlecode
last year and he was
just wrapping up,
and everybody was
applauding, and I
came to the podium I was
like, thanks, thanks Drew.
That was really good.
That made me want
to work at Dropbox.
If I didn't have a
job already I would.
And nobody believed
me, they thought
I was just being facetious.
So, now he hates me.
That's too bad.
That happens to me.
OK, let's get started soon.
So you're all here
because you're
interested in Battlecode.
These lectures are optional.
They're geared at beginner
to mid-level coders,
but they'll be
relevant even if you've
had coding experience
in a million languages.
Because we're
going to be talking
a lot of the time about
Battlecode, the game itself.
And it could just be a
way to keep yourself up
to date on the latest
metagame, for example.
So we're going to go
over the specs today.
I'm going to introduce
the competition.
And then after
lecture today, we'll
be having a lab, during
which we'll help you set up.
So I see a lot of you brought
your computers, that's
fantastic.
And that's also great because
it means if you get bored,
you can just watch
YouTube videos.
Yeah, so make sure to bring
your ear plugs so that you don't
bother the guy next to
you, because he's already
heard Gangnam Style.
All right so be
respectful of those guys.
So here's our introduction.
My name is Maxwell Mann, I'll
be your lecturer for the next 10
days.
It actually is minus 4 days
because of various things.
So it's like the
next two weeks, you
can come here at this
time-- or slightly earlier,
so you can hear a lousy
joke --you can come here,
and you can hear me
talk about the game,
and hear what the
devs think about what
you might need to know.
And then you can eat
food at 6:00 PM, when
we have massive
quantities of food coming,
and then from 6:00 to
7:00, you have the option
of staying for the lab session,
which has been described,
in anticipation,
as a social utopia.
And I really believe
that it could be one,
because everybody here has,
sort of, some similar interests.
So to introduce
us, we developers,
are students, or
alums, who have worked
on developing Battlecode.
I'm Max.
Sitting here in the
front is Aaron Epstein
and Steven Valdez.
You'll be using them for help,
all the time, if you need it,
or just to bother them
because you feel like it.
They're here for
no other reason,
and to maintain the code base
and these kinds of things.
The website is battlecode.org
and we have a forum there,
where you could
also go to get help.
And I also,
particularly, would like
to direct your attention
to the IRC channel.
It's #battlecode on Freenode.
So I don't know if
you know what that is,
but it's basically
a way that you
can talk to us on
a real time chat.
So you can do that at pretty
much any hour of the day,
because the way
we're setting it up
this year is we'll all
be available, pretty
much the whole time.
OK, make sure that if
you are an MIT student,
and you want credit
for this class--
it's a six credit
class --you just
have to sign up on
WebSIS for 6.S187.
How many people have signed
up on WebSIS already?
All right, that's
like everybody.
Let's talk about the
goals of the competition.
What is a game?
What are we doing?
I'm sure a lot of you are
thinking all right, well, here
we go.
I've got finals
tomorrow but I have
to decide what IAP
classes to take.
Gosh, this is a terrible
combination of deadlines.
Then you thought,
should I take--
should I to do battle code?
Should I do one of these other
things, like web programming,
or game programming?
What is the operating
systems whatshumadoosits?
Should I do this or that?
And you're probably thinking
to yourself, what is fun?
What is valuable for me?
What am I going to learn?
And we ask ourselves
the same question.
A couple months
before then was, what
do we want the Battlecode
competition to be like?
And what we ended
up deciding, was
that the game needs
to be fun and it
needs to contain classic
battle code areas of challenge
in artificial intelligence.
So this is a game that
is a cross-- we've always
said in the past that
it is not StarCraft
--but it is a cross between
a real-time strategy
game and an AI
programming competition.
So what we wanted was the
game to be easy to learn,
but hard to master.
So what you'll see when I
describe the game specs--
and I'm going into it just
momentarily --when I describe
game specs you'll see ways
to play the game, and then
ways to excel at the game.
So it's like you've got
this infinite ramp, that you
can run wild on, of
how much effort you
want to put into
developing the best player.
Or better yet, because
what is the best?
It's comparative.
That's comparing
to somebody else.
But that's kind of irrelevant.
What you want is to have fun.
Anyway, you know that.
So there we go.
Our idea was to not
have sort of skill caps
and limiting factors,
like maps that are just
covered in maze so
you can't do anything
unless you can get
past that maze.
Like, OK, you didn't
pass the test,
I hope you enjoy
your starting area.
No, no.
So not that.
So let me show the game.
How many of you have
seen Battlecode before?
A show of hands.
So that's a good number,
but it's not everybody.
So I'm going to show you a game.
So this is when
you've made your code
and you've put it
into the client,
you can run a game
like this, and we'll
go over how to do that.
And I'll just hit
play here, and you'll
see the red team
in the upper left,
and the blue team
in the bottom right,
playing a game of
Battlecode for this year.
The player on the
upper left, in red,
is placing mines,
and capturing bases.
His soldiers are moving around
and fighting with one another.
Fighting the enemy, hopefully.
And the blue player,
here at the bottom right,
is just sort of
shooting his guys off
to die at the enemy army.
On the left you'll
see indicators
of various game constants
and values that are changing.
If I pause this
for a second, you
can see by clicking
on any robot,
you can see his ID number,
what robot type it is.
You can see his hit
point level, which
we have characteristically had
a very difficult to remember
name for.
We always have different names
for their energy and their head
points this year it's going to
be, "energon," for hit points.
I think this flux number is
actually no longer relevant,
and you can ignore it.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: See,
we worked so hard
on making this
polished and perfect,
that we weren't finished
until-- actually we're
not finished yet, they're
still fussing with something.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: The
bytecodes used is going
to be a key factor that you're
going to look at so that you
can determine how much
computational energy
those robots are spending.
This year, there's
a very big impact
on the efficiency of your
code, and the performance
of your player.
If you have efficient code, you
could have twice as many robots
on the field then
you can sustain
if your code is inefficient.
Because the actual
computational cost
is recorded, and
is then implemented
into the upkeep of each unit.
Finally, you'll see the
location of the unit, and three
indicator strings that you can
use for debugging and control
purposes.
So what we'll do today is talk
about what kinds of things
are on this map, and how that's
different and amazingly great,
and how this year's new gameplay
will be even more fun than it
ever has been.
And I can say that
with some confidence,
because it's quite different
and demonstrably better.
Yes.
So what we think of
as skill areas, areas
that make a fun
game for Battlecode,
are, navigation-- but not
that you so much require
it --see, in this example,
they didn't really
need any complex maze
solving algorithms.
What they were just doing, is
there are these neutral mines
that are here, and you
could either walk around
the neutral minefield,
or you could just
clear yourself
right on through it.
So there's navigation,
but you don't necessarily
have to do it.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: There's
group pathing--
and that's a good point
because, you know,
OK, anybody can take one
unit and after enough time,
figure out how to implement
any of the existing pathing
algorithms.
But let's say you've
got multiple units.
They start to get in
one another's way.
Let me give an example
that's very concrete,
and that hits really
close to home, for me.
I did this all the time--
I've done Battlecode,
I guess, like four years now.
And so what I'd always
have is, I'm here,
and I want to go to ice
cream-- something desirable
--and I'm trying to
get past this wall.
So I go here, but then all my
friends take up all this space
because they're
going the same way.
And then I'm trying to
turn around, and go back,
and they're trying to
go this way because they
think it's closer
to the ice cream.
And we just end up here
all day, and then the enemy
comes by and shoots us.
And then we've got
holes in ourselves,
how are we going to
maintain that stomach
area to keep the ice cream in?
It's just not going to work.
So we like navigation,
we like group pathing.
We like messaging.
This year, the messaging
system is totally new.
In the past, what
you'd need is--
I'm going to go
back to the screen
here --is your
robot would only be
able to see a certain
area around himself.
And so every other
robot would not
know what's going on, on the
whole map, except by messaging.
But even then, they would
have to receive messages
that are broadcast
within a certain range.
So you end up having to make
these chains where you'd
say, all right,
I've got, let's see,
Joe, and James, and Jalopy.
They're all in line, and these
three robots are in line,
and they each have
some broadcast radius.
And so maybe I can, sort
of, set up a relay chain,
and they're broadcasting back.
And that was how you used
to communicate information
about where the enemy is.
So here's the ice cream,
here, and here's me.
And I would have to hear
it from these four guys.
But that would end up
being a lot of work
for me to implement.
And we like that, we
think that's really cool.
But at the same time
it ended up meaning
that if the ice
cream were an enemy,
and I needed to scout
that the enemy were coming
with some rush, that
what would often happen
is that there wouldn't
be a chain established.
Because this kind of
stuff's kind of hard do.
So this guy would see the enemy
right here-- and here's me,
back here, I'm just
minding my own business.
Maybe I'm building a staircase,
which we did in one year.
Or some other very useful
expenditure of effort and time.
So this guy sees the enemy
and I don't know about it,
I can't prepare
until he comes back.
OK, so then he comes back
to within broadcast range--
he's here --but by then
the enemy is right there.
I can't do anything.
So what we've done
this year, is we've
said all right, realistically
we've got these radios, right?
Let's communicate, on these
radios, across the whole map.
So now your radio messages can
be heard across the whole map.
But, instead of being messages,
like they used to be--
and these messages
were kind of annoying,
they were these constructs
that you had to assemble.
You'd say, oh, I'm
making a new message
and I'm applying
these parts to it.
And not every message
has every type of part.
And not every part as
every type of message.
And every time I
receive a message
I can receive an
infinity of messages.
And then my robot
explodes because he's
being overloaded with messages.
That's like spam, happens
a lot, it happens to me.
So what we get instead,
is we said, all right,
we've got a uniform
message channel.
We've got 10,000 channels.
And any robot can
post an integer
to any one of those
channels, at any time.
So then my robot could be
posting-- maybe my code
is using frequency 567.
And I'll be communicating on
that frequency specifically
where I'm going, or what
direction I'm going,
or something like that.
And everybody on
my team can see it.
So that's a really useful
sort of centralizing feature.
So if the enemy is
coming, I can just
look on integer number 567, and
if the enemy is coming, maybe
that's a flag,
maybe I make that, I
guess, 666 because
that's really bad.
Right?
So I make that my token for
enemy is coming, and then bing,
everybody can start preparing
for the enemy coming.
But there's more,
I mean, let's say
you're going to metagame them.
You're going to think about what
could happen from a high level.
Like when would the
enemy just invade?
When would they attack me?
I mean, I don't have to see them
coming to know that they will.
For example, maybe the
map is really small.
So this year, you can
tell how big the map is.
I mean, how does it make sense--
this happened again and again
in previous years --how
does it make sense
to have a game, where players
are expected to operate
intelligently, in the
absence of information.
OK, I understand that sometimes
a little bit of uncertainty
can be great.
Like how great poker
be if everybody
knows what everybody
else's hand is?
That would be
really lousy, right?
But here, we just had
almost no information,
so you'd have
build-order losses.
This is sort of a big problem,
in my eyes, with StarCraft.
Which is that you'd start
with a strategy that
could lose before you have any
information on how to fix that.
So at least in StarCraft
you know how big the map is.
So here we're giving them
the following centralized
information.
So here's what I'll do.
I'm going to list out the
centralized information
that you can use, that
you didn't really used
to have access to.
Now you might ask, all right
I'm not going to memorize this,
and I'm not taking
notes-- even though I
did bring a thingamabober, which
is a computer, or a notebook.
You might say, I'm not
going to memorize this,
I'm not interested,
I'm here to have fun.
Well look here, you can
look in the Java docs
and you can see all of
the robot abilities.
They're listed in
this giant list here,
and you'll have time
to peruse those.
And we'll sort of go
over them over the course
of the few lectures.
But having them sort
of in a condensed form
or organized into
topics, like what
is centralized information?
You know, what
information can I use?
Ends up probably being
a bit of a convenience.
So I have a couple of convenient
organizations of data.
And that's really all
I'm here for is just--
you can get all this information
in our documentation,
which we'll supply you when
we help you set up the game.
And/or you can sort of hear
it from me, where I've got it
sort of organized into a
slightly different way.
The centralized
info that you get
includes, you can sense the
positions of all allied robots.
So there's a function, and
again, we have very good naming
conventions so that all
of the names that we pick
let you know exactly
what we're referring to.
And for this function we call
it-- it's a method called,
"Sense Nearby Game Objects."
And that's great because
it can detect game objects
across the map, anywhere,
they don't have to be nearby.
So that that's really nice.
And it senses these things,
which of course, you
would want to sense.
They're objects!
You know, I was playing chess
the other day with my friend
Rick, and I said
to him, you know
what I could use more
of is game objects.
I can sense all of
your game objects.
And he didn't get it.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So Sense
Nearby Game Objects
is an overloaded
function, which means
that you can call it
with multiple arguments.
And that really does help you.
So the point is, this
is a global function,
because you can see any game
object if that game object is
of a certain type.
So all of your allied
robots you can see.
Let's go back to our example,
let's say that I am back here,
that's me, over
here at the bottom.
And this guy up
at the top, I can
see where he is back from here.
But my sight range is
actually only here.
So I've got different
detection abilities.
Allied robots, allied
mines, and neutral mines,
are all visible no
matter where you are,
but enemy robots are only
visible within your sight
radius.
But it's within any
allied robot site radius.
It's harder to explain
than it is to think about.
In this picture, this
robot can see these guys,
because he's really close.
But this guy can also see them,
because this robot is nearby.
Right, that's pretty
straightforward.
One person was nodding
but he was also yawning,
so he may have been nodding off.
No, I'm only joking.
Yeah, zing!
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Sense
Nearby Game Objects
is a kind of useful
thing to be able to do,
but it's not always
obvious how to use it.
So, later on, I'll
be talking about how
one of the inputs to
this is what type of game
object you want.
I still haven't-- I've been
saying game object over
and over, but none of you
care about game objects.
You care about
enemy robots, I want
to shoot at the enemy robots.
So you would end up writing,
oh, I want a robot please.
So you tell it, give me game
objects of type Robot.class.
And you would say,
all right, this
is getting kind of confusing.
I'm feeling a little
bit overwhelmed.
Well don't you worry about it,
because here in the Java Docs,
under package-- and you might
notice that this is the Java
docs version 7,
for Java version 7.
It's real sleek.
We're distributing this
at absolutely no cost.
Yeah.
Let's see here, oh, look!
It's game object.
There it is.
And oh, look, subinterfaces
include encampments and robots.
Well that's great, that
answers my question.
So now I know that I can put
Robot.class or Encampment.class
and it will give me that
type of game object.
Yeah.
Yeah!
All right.
[LAUGHS]
So that's a piece of
centralized information.
Another piece of
centralized info--
so we've talked about
how it's allied robots.
There's allied mines.
I'll talk about the mines and
how you can lay them and defuse
them, and how you get these
things onto the game board.
Allied robots, allied mines.
You've got the radio system,
which is entirely global.
And that means that you can
disrupt somebody else's radio
program.
I have a hunch that there are
several people out there who
would broadcast random numbers
to my favorite channel, 567,
and it would just
totally ruin my player.
I wouldn't be able
to work at all.
Now, in order to limit
this sort of-- there's sort
of a back and forth
between sending messages
that you want to send,
receiving the messages
with a certain amount of,
sort of, redundancy in there,
so you can be safe
against message jamming,
versus actual jamming itself.
How do we assess the balance
of these competing objectives?
Well we've got a cost
associated with everything.
There's no free lunch.
Except dinner for Battlecode.
And that is actually free.
We ordered so much
pizza for today.
Now I'm sure not many of you
ordered that much pizza before.
But let me tell
you that I expected
that-- there's like 120
people here in the room,
and we thought how much
pizza does everybody eat?
Well unfortunately Battlecode
is a male dominated class.
So we'll have slightly
more pizza consumption
than otherwise.
Is that sexist?
And so--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So we decided
to get 50 pizzas.
And we were like, well
what's awesome pizza?
We like Bertucci's.
You guys don't like Bertucci's.
Yeah!
He likes Bertucci's.
Yeah, so that was
like $20 a pizza.
So it was like $1000 for pizza.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: My goodness.
Well anyway, it's going
to be really good.
And it's coming in
like a half an hour.
That's fantastic-- I've totally
lost my train of thought.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Right I was
AUDIENCE: --message him.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I was saying that there's
no free lunch, and as such,
we have a bytecode cost.
Now, I think in the past it's
not been that obvious to me
what the cost of doing a
certain computation is.
Can I jam the enemy?
Is that really going to work, or
am I going to run out of money?
Is a question you could ask.
So here, in the--
let's see here,
I have a place where I
have installed Battlecode.
And you're going to
do something just
like this, where you'll have
that Battlecode-- that's OK,
he had to go to the bathroom.
Don't worry about him.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Well it's a
reasonable supposition,
he is human, isn't he?
All right, and so here, in
the Battlecode directory
where I've installed
Battlecode, there's
going to be a text file
that's called method costs.
Bingo.
All right now it
looks disorganized
because everything-- the
strings are different lengths.
But each string represents
a function that you can use.
Like for example attack square.
Or maybe broadcast a message.
Ah, that was the one
we were interested in.
OK, let's look at that.
Broadcast costs 25 bytecodes.
All right, let's do a little
bit of math-- arithmetic,
it's not math, is it?
25 bytecodes, all right?
There are 10,000 strings,
which I wrote and erased.
10,000 places to
write a message to.
There are 25 bytecodes
to broadcast a message.
OK, so that means that I
can broadcast 400 messages.
Is that right?
Is that this number divided by
that number equals that number?
Is that-- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, let's go with it.
Yeah, let's go with that.
So you have 400.
No, but maybe you have more of
your robots jamming signals.
OK, how many robots
can you have?
All right, let's do
that computation.
I'm pretending that I'm you,
and that I'm just like-- OK
I'm not doing a very
good impersonation.
I recognize that.
You'd be much faster at this.
So you would want to find
out how many robots you
can sustain.
Can I get somebody to
suggest one way to figure out
that number?
Yes!
You, you, you.
Ah yes you could make a
player and just spawn robots
until they start dying.
Let's say you wanted to
do it in a different way.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: I have
the example here.
What is It?
Game constants, there we are.
So here I'm looking
at the Java docs,
and I can click
on game constants.
I'm looking at a
different version of it
that didn't actually show the
game constants in the game
constants page.
But that's because we
are well organized.
And this is to show that we're
indomitable, indefatigable,
as it were.
These constant values
indicate, here,
that your headquarters
is capable of producing
quite a few resources.
This shows that it produces
50 resources per turn.
This resource
production enables you
to have an upkeep of robots.
So in the past, we've had
names like flux, and so on.
This year, the name
for it is power.
That's tough though because
we have time as well.
And as you well know power
times time is energy.
And so now we have
energon and energy,
which is a multiple or a
calculated quantity from power.
But don't you worry
too much about it.
It's just a number.
And the usage of this
resource, or power, by robots,
is displayed in unit upkeep.
Which here, is
written incorrectly.
I'm going to be
bring up the most
recent version of this document.
What's nice is that you
guys will get one version,
and then you'll have one
version on your computer
and not, like, 16.
And your one version
will be up to date.
And when you want to
update it, the client
will automatically tell
you that it needs updating.
So you'll just have
the one version,
and you won't have
disaster area.
Yeah, constant value.
So this is the more
recently updated one.
And you can see here the
unit power upkeep is one.
All right, fantastic.
We're ready to do a computation.
So I'm going to
put here 40 divided
by-- so this is the
amount of energy,
or the amount of
power, that's produced
per turn by your
headquarters divided
by the usage of that power.
Now you're going to say,
all right, I'm bored.
I can do this in my head.
Well maybe you can but some
of us can't, all right?
No, so that would be the number.
But that would say that the
number of robots you get
is independent of how
much work they're doing.
And that doesn't make any sense.
You should get to
have more robots
if you're doing
less computation.
So here you can see,
there is a cost.
Power cost per
bytecode, which is here.
And it's 10 to the minus 4.
So let's say that I'm
using-- 10 to the minus 4
times the number bytecodes.
Well, if I'm using zero
byte codes, then I get 40.
Because that would be 1 plus 0.
And 40 over one is 40.
OK and if I were
using 10,000, which
is also known as 10 to the 4.
Then I would get 20.
Wow, what a big difference.
So that tells you that if
you want to go ahead and spam
the message system--
let's say you're spamming,
so you're using all of
your bytecodes possible,
and you have 20 robots.
So 20 robots are spamming 400
message integers per turn.
So you're doing nothing
but spamming the messages.
And you're getting eight,
zero, zero, ze-- Oh, ahh, ahh.
Oh, it's not even enough.
It's not enough.
Well, so that shows that
you could jam the enemy.
And maybe you should, if you've
got nothing better to do,
if you derive a personal
satisfaction from it.
But this is worth saying.
These kinds of calculations
are important for strategy.
But don't make them
totally fixed in stone.
Because we change
the game, we tweak
it a little bit for balance.
So if it ends up being that
10,000 is just so much radio
space that we just would
rather not have it,
then it could just get
knocked down to 1000.
And then all of a sudden
your player, which
depends on this or that
messaging construct,
may have to be
somewhat rethought.
So this is a good time to
talk about the organization
of the competition.
Is it?
I think it is.
Let's go to the
Battlecode website.
And let me show you something.
I don't know I knew
that you could do this.
But previous years
we've had like a list.
And it'll be in
text form, and it'll
say on this date we have this
competition, and this one.
And then you have to
open up a window of this.
And then every single
one of you opens up
another window with
Gmail or Google Calendar.
And then you like manually enter
in the-- do you not do that?
Who has to do that whenever
you have a competition,
you want to know
when things are?
Yeah, yeah there's
like two people who
also have to do that.
So I figured, in light of saving
those two people some effort,
we made this Google Calendar.
And you could see, here's
today's classroom session,
here in 1-190 from
5:00 to 6:00 PM.
And it's got the
lab written there.
So the specs and software are
released, as of 37 minutes ago,
roughly speaking.
And what we'll
do, after this, is
we'll talk about
how to set it up.
So there you go, specs
and software are released.
The sprint tournament
is on the 14th.
And what that means is you
can submit a player for that,
and you can be entered for a
relatively small prize pool.
Relatively small,
the actual prize
pool for the finals
is I think $50,000.
So relatively small
is just some fraction
of that which is
still non-negligible.
Anyway, so that's going to be
really exciting because that
will give you the opportunity
to test your code out
to see what other players
are doing, because to
some extent winning
is going to be
related to what other people do.
But more importantly,
having fun is
related to what other
people do, and talking
to the other people.
Like this social utopia of
mine, the idea of this lab,
is totally new-- as well
as the Google Calendar
--to try to make things more
easy and fun and together,
among us as Battlecoders.
Because we do all
share that common link.
Yes.
So the point is
that if you didn't
know you could do
this, what you do
is you go to-- if you want to
add this to your own calendar,
there's like a button where
you can go and do that.
I think the button isn't
available because-- Yeah,
there.
There?
At the bottom.
At the bottom?
Yeah, there you go.
And then you just
add it right in,
so I've already got it here,
in my personal calendar.
And there you go, so
you can see that I'm
having lunch on the 24th.
And OK, so you get the idea.
So the sprint tournament
is-- the submission deadline,
you can see here,
is on the 14th.
On the 16th, on that
Wednesday, in class,
we'll show some of the games
from the sprint tournament.
I don't think we'll
show all of them.
See because what used to happen,
is we would show all the games.
And there's like 100 teams.
And that ends up being
a relatively large size
round-robin bracket with, I
think, double elimination.
So it's a ton of games.
I think it generally
takes like five hours.
But it ends up bumping up to
six, seven, or eight hours
because we end up
showing up there,
and the tournament code that
sets it all up doesn't work.
And so it takes forever.
So we're going to
do this year is
we'll just sort to
distill it down,
we'll have something
simple to show
that's fantastic and
exciting on the Wednesday.
And in the future, when we
have our later-- our seating
tournament, which is sort
of the same kind of thing,
but it's more important, because
it determines your positioning
for the final tournament.
When we have this
seating tournament,
we're going to live
stream it on the internet,
so that you don't
even have to-- I mean,
you guys all trekked out
here in the dead of night
and 5:00 or 6:00 PM
in the freezing cold.
I mean there could be people out
there dying because they tried
to make it here and
they didn't make it.
That would be horrible, that's
not something to laugh at.
So you came all
the way out here,
but we don't want to make you
have to do that much work.
Because we want you to have fun.
So there you go.
We've got a calendar to
save you that effort.
We have lab sessions to save
you the effort of trying
to make friends, and
we'll have live streams
in the future, which will
make that much better.
So as you can see here, it
says the seating tournament
submission deadline
is on the 21st.
And the seating tournament
will be on the 22nd.
So what that does, is it gets
you your position in the finals
tournament.
The finals submission
deadline is different, though.
So you can continually
update your player.
My point is that you
only have three weeks.
It's the 7th today.
And the finals submission
deadline is the 28th.
You have three weeks to
make an amazing player.
And each week, you'll
have the chance
to-- you could upload
your player at any time,
you can do scrimmage matches
with other players at any time.
And then finally, you'll be
able to submit to the finals.
I mean, I don't think it's
worth getting too hyped up
about this final thing because
after all, in my experience,
game changes at the last minute
screw you over at the finals,
and ends up being a crap shoot.
No, no, I exaggerate.
But the point is, the fun
should be had as you go.
And I am here to help with that.
So what you need--
so just one more
thing about this
administration is
that I think that it's required
that you upload a resume,
and that you be an MIT student
if you want to earn-- no,
that's not right.
We have international
competitors, this year.
We have sort of a thing going on
with the University of Sussex.
If you have friends
at other universities,
they can feel free to join you.
And they don't have
to be MIT students
to either play or win money.
And if they're in
Honolulu, or Alaska,
we'll fly them in
here for the finals
because we expect the finalists
to show up at this dinner
that we have at the Hyatt.
We have this fantastically
lavish dinner.
I think we paid
like $5,000 for it.
Aaron, could you
come up here and show
what the sponsors
are by just turning
your back to the audience?
No, actually there's a
button here, I can do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's a good point.
OK, so here are our sponsors.
We have these fancy company
reps show up at this dinner.
So if you're among
the finalists,
then you show up at
the fancy reps dinner
and they offer you
jobs and stuff.
It's apparently very
nice, I've never been.
AUDIENCE: [AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
Yeah, that's because I was busy.
Yeah, that's why.
That's why.
No.
So these are some
of the sponsors.
Our main sponsors
and some other ones.
And you'll get a chance to meet
them, as well, at the finals.
So you don't have to be the best
of the best by whatever stupid
metric we come up with.
What you have to
be is-- anybody who
does Battlecode is an attractive
person to these employers who
will meet you and give
you business cards.
And it'll be a good
time for everyone.
And so in that note
you have, once again,
on the calendar page, the finals
are on the 2nd of February.
So that'll be when that
happens and it'll be in 26-100.
It'll be a blast, and you
should be looking forward
to that very much.
I feel like I've
just been droning on,
ranting about what I don't
like about StarCraft.
And I haven't talked enough
about the things that
are related to
gameplay this year.
This year, you
have these robots.
It's astounding to me, that I--
Oh, is that why it didn't work?
Because I was using this
one instead of this one,
and I meant to use
this main client?
Yeah, that's the one.
OK, yeah.
This was the point I was
trying to make earlier.
Where I was going to
take compute time bot,
playing against compute
time bot, on this map.
This is sort of how
to do it, but it'll
be done a little
bit differently.
And so the goal here is to see
how many robots can be built.
But this guy-- Ah!
I think team A and
B got switched.
So what I'll do is I'll just
briefly switch around the code.
So this is sort of the
structure of a robot controller.
What happens is this code is
run on each robot on your team,
and that's what plays the game.
I'm sure most of you
know that already.
And so what I'll do is I'll
just check that the team is B.
So I can switch the team,
hit Save, run it again.
Well it doesn't
work as well as I
was expecting because
these guys are just
dying when they go
through the minefield.
That's interesting.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: You know, you can
make your own maps in this.
This is a really good
example of debugging.
And you can say that
I did this on purpose.
Although if you have a
strict adherence to honesty,
you might not.
So the maps are located where?
You're looking at what, here?
So you'll have a directory
where you can see your maps.
And you'll be also
able to see them here.
So here's simple.
And what if I want
to edit this map.
Can I do that?
Can I just double click it?
It's an XML document.
Oh, look.
Is it?
Oh, data, OK.
Here's some data.
I'm beginning to get
to the part-- see,
this would be really
easy if I could just
do edit with notepad.
AUDIENCE: --source at the bottom
PROFESSOR: Source!
No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Tab.
AUDIENCE: No, down.
PROFESSOR: Down?
Down.
AUDIENCE: Where design is.
PROFESSOR: Oh!
Bingo.
All right!
Yeah, thank you.
So then, you can
see that I can make
my own maps using these codes.
So the character "3"
indicates a neutral mine.
So I can just do like a find
replace, were I'll replace "3"
with ".", which is
an open terrain.
I'll just do replace all.
And then I'll just
make sure to change
this one or else the
whole map would be mines.
I'm sure two of you thought
that I wouldn't do that,
but I assure you that I'm
operating at full capacity.
All right, so this is an
example where you can see I've
just built bunch of robots.
And you can see that
this is my power.
Your power stored
in a reserve bank.
And what I'm going to do
is suddenly at round 1,000,
I'm going to start
computing a lot.
So right now you can
see that this robot
is using 38 bytecodes.
Not very many.
If you're amazing
at counting you'll
see that there
are about 40 here.
And the new robots-- oh, boom!
Look at that.
The new robots died because they
don't have enough-- these guys
don't have enough compute-- they
don't have enough power to run.
So they lose hit points
until they're dead.
And then if they all
start using code,
boom, when we cut down
to half the number.
And so you could
see quite visually
the effect of using 10,000
bytecodes versus using
no bytecodes at all.
So from here, down to there.
Bang.
This power quantity can be
affected by various things.
So there are some equations that
I could show for what that is.
But maybe I've just gone
a bit far field here
because I've been talking
about some details.
Here's the general
overview, right?
You don't really need too
many of the specifics,
because all you've got
to do is find the enemy.
And there's a function
that does that.
Oh, look at that, I'll just
add that to the global list.
There's, "Sense Enemy
Headquarters," bingo.
Done.
If you were interested in
a little bit of masochism,
coding masochism, and just
doing something the hard way,
you could do that.
Because what we've
also provided,
is the dimensions
of the map, and you
know that the upper left
corner of the map is 0,0.
So with a symmetry
operation you could say,
my headquarters is here.
The map size is this.
My location is here.
Therefore, the enemy must
be at this other location.
So more than one way to skin
a cat, as the case may be.
So you locate the enemy,
and all you have to do
is walk up to him.
Because this year attacking
happens automatically
for soldiers.
So right now there isn't
any fighting going on.
But I'll show an
example that will
show that all they've got to
do is go near one another,
and then their attack
power is distributed
among all of the
robots they can see.
So this is some old
code that we were
writing when we were
testing the game.
And what you'll
find is that when
robots come close
to one another,
they make these circles that
indicate their attack range.
So they're attacking-- this
guy is distributing his attack
among this one and that one.
Similarly, this one is
distributing among these three.
So his attack power in
this version of the game
was different.
But right now I believe
the attack power is six.
So he would be dealing two
damage to each of these.
What you also see in
this picture, which
I believe is quite instructive,
is the shield robots.
Yeah, any robot that's standing
next to this shields robot
will be given this
additional shields parameter.
And so you can see it here
in the user interface.
There's a green bar
indicating health,
and a blue bar
indicating shields.
In the latest implementation
of Battlecode,
shields serve as
a protection only
against a certain type of
encampment that can be built.
So is these encampments
work in the following way.
You start with just
a headquarters,
and that produces
these soldiers.
So you can produce a soldier
at any tile around you,
if that tile is unoccupied.
That soldier can then be used
to construct an encampment.
And he can construct any of a
number of types of encampment.
So I've made this nice, handy,
useful Battlecode data sheet.
People from last
year might remember
that I made sort of a handy
unit sheet at that time.
But this year it's 100% more
accurate than last year's.
That's right.
We've checked and
double checked,
but this is the latest version.
So you can see here all of
the different types of units.
And there's a Boolean for
whether it is an encampment,
in terms of just a description.
Although, you know, that's kind
of not a fantastic description.
Because all of these
units-- you know,
because we like to
be straightforward.
It's a realistic
preparation for your life
as a professional coder, that
the database and documentation
you receive will contain
information opposite to the way
that things are run.
So you can see here that they're
all listed-- some of these
are listed as encampments.
But in fact they are all robots.
Yes, I believe that's correct.
They are all robots.
So the headquarters is
what you start with.
It generates 40 power turn, and
it can spawn these soldiers.
It takes 10 turns
to spawn a soldier.
Or it can research upgrades,
and I'll talk about the upgrades
below, in just a minute.
The soldier has an upkeep
of 1 to 2 power per turn,
depending on byte code usage.
It automatically
distributes its attack power
among adjacent enemy units.
And it has the
capability of laying
mines, which take 25
turns to lay a mine.
Defusing mines, which take
5 turns, and capturing
encampments, which
takes 50 turns.
Now you might ask,
all right, where
am I getting these numbers?
I'm assembling this
sort of convenient
diagram but what if
the specs change?
You know, where do
I get these numbers?
Well they're all under game
constants under robot type
enum, or the upgrade
enum, and you'll
find them all the Java docs.
Alternatively, you
could all always
ask us where they are by
going on our IRC chat,
or talking to one
of us in person.
So you can see here they're
laying mines, defusing mines,
capturing encampments.
And in the act of capturing
one of these encampments, which
is a pre-existing location on
the map, these black circles.
In the act of capturing
one of those--
there's nothing
magical about it.
Because here, among the
robot controller methods,
you'll find capture encampment.
And what you'll do is
you'll specify what type
of enchantment
you want it to be.
And you might ask,
what types are there?
Well, you could either
look at handy chart,
or you could click
here, under robot type.
And this enum robot type
will show you the types
that you can build.
You can build artillery,
generator, medbay, shields,
and supplier.
The headquarters and
soldier are different.
They're not built
from encampments.
I don't know if that's written
anywhere, but I've said it,
so now you know it.
Yeah.
So that's how you're going to be
able to build these units, that
are shown here.
So the medbay heals adjacent
robots, 2 hit points per turn.
You can see that's their quote,
"attack power," because attack
is a lot like healing.
You know, modern surgery,
you can use scalpel and such.
These are also
considered weapons.
I'm sure you couldn't
bring a scalpel on a plane.
So attack is a really good word
for healing-- a healing unit.
And if you don't believe me talk
to any medicine man you know.
Shields will give
all adjacent robots
5 shield points per turn.
So if you cluster 8
units around them,
then that'll go ahead and give
40 shield points distributed
among them, to the extent
that 5 times 8 is 40.
The shields only protect
you from artillery, though.
They don't protect you
against other soldiers.
Now, these robots
that are shielded
will lose 1 shield point
per turn, as it wears off.
But there's no cap on the
amount of shields they can have.
So they can have, I think,
10 to the 8th shields.
Which is like a lot more than
their total hit points of 40.
Right?
So that's effectively infinite.
The artillery is the one unit
that can shoot at a far range.
It could shoot at a range of 63.
Now we always talk
about squared ranges,
because that makes it
easier to do comparisons
without having to
take a square root.
Although I guess if we
did give you ranges,
and not squared ranges, you
could just square it and then
compare it to the range that
you had just calculated.
this way works really well.
So what I can do is I can
demonstrate for you what that
looks like by opening
up-- oh my goodness,
I'm almost out of time.
I can open up this stockpiling--
no, that's not right.
I made it in the map
maker program, down here.
Yeah, so this shows
you what 63 looks like.
So if you're here in the middle,
you can see all of these tiles
but you can't see
the ones outside.
But its site range is only 14.
Every robot has a site range
of 14, As you can see here,
in this document.
So the attack range is
63, the site range is 14.
So, this is one of
those cases where
you'd need scouting units that
would know what to shoot at.
And it's really helpful that you
have this global information.
Because you don't
need to post to radio
to tell the artillery
what to shoot at.
Because he can already
see all of the unit
that your allies can see.
He can't necessarily
see the enemies,
unless your guys are nearby.
So, yes, the artillery does
40 damage to the target
that it specifies, and 20
splash damage to adjacent tiles.
And that does include
friendly fire,
so you've got to be careful
about where you shoot.
The generator generates
10 resources per turn.
And that resource is power.
So that's added on to
your headquarter power.
So if you build a
bunch of generators,
you can support more soldiers.
And finally, the
supplier will reduce
the build time for
soldiers by 5%.
And that's multiplicative.
So if you have two
suppliers, then it's
0.95 squared times 10 turns.
This year, we give
you the opportunity
of building upgrades as
well, researching upgrades
at your headquarters.
So your headquarters
is your central unit,
the goal is to defeat
the enemy headquarters.
To do that, you could just
walk your robots on over
and kill them dead.
It's not required that
you research upgrades
and built encampments.
And that's one of
the ways that we
make the competition
somewhat easier to enter,
easier to get
something that works.
But if you want to
research upgrades,
to make a strategy
that's tailored
around a certain approach,
then you can get these.
The future upgrade
reduces your energy decay
because the way
that you hold power,
is that you can't just
mass it up indefinitely.
You get a power income
from your headquarters,
and you spend power to
upkeep your soldiers.
But we don't want that--
if you have no soldiers
and you're just
getting income, we
don't want that to
go up indefinitely.
So every turn that
gets multiplied
by a number that reduces it.
So the energy decay,
or the loss is 20%.
But if you research fusion,
the loss is only 1%.
So then you might think
of stockpiling energy
and then spending it all
at once to get a larger
burst of robots, which couldn't
be sustained for a long time.
But then again, you only
have to win one second.
Finally, the-- OK, so then
there's more upgrades.
Vision upgrade extends your
squared vision from 10 to 32.
This should say 14, but
as you know everything
is always up to date
100 percent of the time.
So here's a demonstration of
what that would look like.
Here's 10 and here's 32.
Boom, what a big difference.
That's quite a lot more vision.
That's important because
you can defuse any mine
within your site range if you
have the diffusion ability.
Which is not to be confused
with chemical diffusion, which
is something else.
Yes, this is for
defusing things,
and it is spelled correctly.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So yeah, that extends
your mine defusing range.
That's pretty important,
but keep in mind
that you can still only
defuse one at a time.
So you have to select which
one you're going to defuse.
And then you defuse that.
Now, it's important
to note that you
can see where-- I've said that
you see your allied mines.
I haven't said that you can
see your neutral mines as well.
But you don't see enemy mines
until one of your robots
has stepped on it.
So that means that you can't--
I don't think you can defuse
something you can't see.
But actually I don't know,
I'll have to check with that.
Because it may be that
you could just spam
defuse on terrain
that you don't know.
And that might actually defuse
things that you can't see.
At the same time, that's
not a fantastic strategy,
because defused takes 5 turns.
And during those 5
turns you cannot attack.
So that leaves you--
or can you attack?
I'm thinking maybe
you can attack.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: You know what, you
can't-- it's a very vulnerable
position, to be
defusing something.
Because you're concentrating
on something else.
How do you going to
perform as effectively
on a different task?
Pickaxe is the tool
that you really
need if you want to
lay a ton of mines.
Because instead of laying just
one mine, where your robot is--
I guess I'm going
to have to come up
with a system for
describing robot--
that's sort of like a robot.
Maybe it's a Chinese character.
So that's a robot,
and ordinarily he
would lay a mine here,
but if you have pickaxe,
he will lay mines in
all of these positions
for the same cost of
laying just one mine.
Pretty useful to have.
And it takes the same amount.
So laying a mine cost
25 rounds, defusing
a mine costs five rounds.
So you could do the math.
If you have pickaxe,
you could lay them
as fast as the other
team can defuse them,
provided you can get into an
open space where you can do it.
Realistically they might be
able to encroach, and get you
during that time.
And why do you
want to lay mines?
Doesn't that slow the game down?
Doesn't that mean
that things will just
move to slowly, make it
a boring thing to watch?
I would say no, because
during that time
you could be researching
the nuclear missile.
That's right.
That's right, we
knew that it would
be interesting to watch
players build nuclear missiles.
If you research that,
you win immediately.
So--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
That's yet another
fun way to win,
and I'm going to show you an
example of somebody attempting
to win that way.
This will only take as
much time as it took me
the last time I tried to do it.
It's under-- golly, you won't
have nearly-- oh, it's right
here.
It must be so hard to watch
me, because it's like, oh man,
he's looking right at it.
Let's see, so let's
put do nothing bot--
because that's a decent
match for the nuke bot.
Where is he?
Is he not here?
AUDIENCE: No, he's
in the middle.
PROFESSOR: He's in the middle.
Oh, I'm looking right at him.
All right.
All right, well it's by no
means a foregone conclusion
who wins this match.
This is an old version
of the code where
nuking took 1,000 turns
instead of 400 turns.
But that's not to say that
the red team will necessarily
win on turn 1,000.
Oh wait.
It could only take 400
turns wait a minute.
Oh, that's 1,000 and
this was-- OK yeah, hey!
It happened.
There you go.
So yeah, the nuclear
missile has-- I mean,
it's not a very
impressive graphic.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: It's
technically the same one
we use for every
other explosion.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: But I think what
we'll do is for the finals,
we've got a new
match visualizer.
So this was an old
version of the code,
because of course I wouldn't
show you something up to date.
That would be that help
you instead of hinder you.
And what we're trying to do
is train you to be amazing.
And it's working, I swear.
So what I'll do is I'll show
this version of it, which
is great, because it shows
the thing researching.
All right, well later
versions of the client
that you're going
to receive will
show what things are researching
in the client window.
And I think it really would
not be in an excessive--
the pizza should be
arriving any moment,
so I know that the
gurgling of your stomachs
is totally reasonable and
will be resolved imminently.
If I run this version,
then I think-- let's see,
is there-- so let's put do
nothing against the nuke guy.
Is the nuke guy still there?
He is, OK.
So this version of
the map viewer shows
researches that are going on.
Yeah.
And you can see he's researching
pickaxe, diffusion, sight
range, the fusion
thing that reduces
the amount of energy loss.
He's researching everything.
And whereas the other do
nothing guy-- you know,
you could describe
him as a pacifist.
The philosophy that
he is developing,
using three bytecodes per
round, may change the world.
So I see no reason to hate
on his choice of vocation.
I would definitely not--
yeah, no, definitely.
OK.
So you can see here that
nuke is researching.
So in a tournament
scenario we could all
start getting excited
and going ohhhhh!
What's going to happen?
Is it going to be close?
And that sort of thing.
I mean of course at
the end it's going
to be a bit of an
anti-climax because it's
going to show a
little puff ball,
like somebody made
popcorn on one tile.
But we'll be able to overcome
that because we can just
switch to YouTube
and show a clip
of some giant nuclear test.
All right, that's all
I have for you now.
I mean to say that
we're going to show
you a whole bunch of things.
You can get up and go,
I know a lot of you
have appointments with very
attractive young women and men.
And that's totally OK.
But I recommend that you
stick around, eat some pizza,
hear about how to
set up Battlecode.
And know that we will have
our developer testing code up.
The team name, here on
the Battlecode website.
You can see here, team list.
We just made a team that you can
use to test your code against.
That's down here at the bottom.
It's test, somewhere.
Yeah, Teh Devs
Test, there you go.
Did you guys make this many
teams in the last 2 seconds?
You must have.
You know, it's
important to multitask.
Yeah, so you can
upload your player
and test it against
Teh Devs test player.
And that'll be
available all the time,
and that's probably
sort of your first step
on your road to success.
Thank you very much for coming,
and if you have any questions
you can come to us after.
[APPLAUSE]